[Music]
over the years i've received plaques
weird shaped glass awards with my name
on it big picture frames that you can't
really reuse because it says stuff like
rewards conference 2010.
it's kind of random things you get at
conferences and banquets
although i'm really happy to have the
memories of the award or whatever the
situation was the physical mementos have
no meaning in my life and i can't think
of how to repurpose them and i can't
stand thinking about them sitting in a
landfill forever if i throw them away so
i'm just curious what you guys would do
with them
what do you do with all your awards josh
all the awards i give you for best
friend
runner-up here's the uh here's the
plaque for runner-up best friend
you know it's fascinating because i have
two answers for this ryan one is what i
did with mine which was rather symbolic
and i wouldn't recommend that's why
we're calling this this episode the
dumpster method because it's not about
throwing things out
if i could go back and learn from my
mistakes of decluttering i threw too
many things out up front without trying
to repurpose them in a way that would be
useful for other people now symbolically
it was awesome
because i just literally took a trash
can and took i mean i had these heavy
really nice presidents yeah man they
were like glass and like yeah a lot of
weight to them for sure you had the same
ones right yeah yeah man yeah yeah i uh
yeah i tossed mine because
hindsight i would have donated them
because i know there's like you know
some eclectic person out there that
would like because the awards were
beautiful
i mean you know they could have been
like an art piece you know or a weapon
they were heavy or a weapon yeah so i
know that like
you know they probably would have
eventually gotten tossed but at least
the opportunity like to be put out there
for someone to grab and you know some
hipster out there who's like oh i got
the number one present i have no idea
what this means but i have number one
president's club award
and uh yeah i mean the landfill thing
the thing i always say
is
as soon as you purchase an item soon you
brought an item into your house it's
you've already done the damage to the
environment
so you know she says she doesn't she
can't picture the the awards sitting
there in a landfill forever
um but she also can't picture them
sitting on her shelf forever and at
least in the landfill they will
decompose a little faster than the
decomposition that will happen on your
shelf
um but yeah i say i say donate them man
that's what if i could go back that's
what i would have done i would have
donated them in fact i've got some
instructions on how you can donate them
and so we'll get real practical on this
because i think this is a practical one
and you can learn from my mistake
because i don't regret what i did but if
i go back and change it i didn't regret
it for a while but i learned the lesson
as soon as you learn the lesson you let
go of the regrets yes right and so we
talked about that on our consumer
regrets episode a few weeks back and
there were two things i wanted to note
here ryan one is i looked up like
artistic things you can do with your old
awards and trophies and i found this
pinterest board with like 141 ideas
for your old trophies and they all
looked aesthetically horrible oh my god
they were awful they were hideous
there's 141 bad ideas on what to do with
your trophies people were using them as
coat hangers and like like you know what
for some people
that kitchiness works well and so when i
say they're horrible i'm just projecting
my own aesthetic yes sensibilities
preferences desires yeah but for i might
actually see it in someone else's house
it would look so out of place in my
house but i might see in someone else's
house say that's really cool that you
did that yeah and that you turned your
old president's club awards into coat
hangers or
into i mean they had all kinds of ideas
in fact sean if you can find that
pinterest board put it in the show notes
please
but then let's get real practical here
right right since she said she has
awards plaques think about plaque for a
second
we go to the dentist to get rid of
plaque
is that what they're taking off
and yet in our homes we cling to the
plaque what a metaphor yeah but if
you're if you really want to let go of
these things because they're no longer
adding value to your life
you can take pictures of them obviously
and
that way you still have the memory
trigger in your home but this is an
article ryan from recyclebank we'll put
a link to this in the show notes as well
it's called what can i do with old
trophies and metals
old trophies and metals are often made
from recyclable materials but they also
hold value in their current form and
many can be reused a number of companies
have programs dedicated specifically to
the art of refurbishing trophies the
best known of these include total awards
and promotions and there's a link in the
article to that place they're in madison
wisconsin and lamb awards and engraving
in westminster maryland these programs
break unwanted awards down for parts
like if you steal a car and then you're
like
you sell it for parts we're in the wrong
business
we can steal trophies that's right
actually
i think you have to pay to for them to
do this but
i think it's like a dollar or something
anyway let me let me just go to the rest
of the article and we can talk about it
here
rebuilding new trophies and plaques with
whichever parts are usable and recycling
the rest so they recycle it for you so
you don't have to worry about it you
don't want to put in landfill they'll
reuse or recycle these for you the
rebuilt items are then donated to
non-profit organizations or resold both
programs will allow you to ship trophies
that are in sufficiently good condition
for nominal processing and shipping fees
please note their restrictions
while medals are accepted by these
groups there are also options dedicated
specifically to giving metals a new life
sports metal recycling there's a link in
here as well a massachusetts-based
organization contributes the proceeds
from recycling donated medals to
fundraising for charity runs the medals
are removed from their ribbons and
sorted for scrap recycling while the
ribbons are sent to cloth slash textile
recycling sports metal recycling even
makes sure that all the packing
materials you use to send them the goods
are recycled as well from bubble wrap to
cardboard boxes
so you get the point you can read the
rest of the article there but it shows
you that there are actually some places
the article goes on to say if you feel
bad about like shipping off your old
trophies or maybe you just can't afford
it then you can check with your local
there they're always going to be local
trophy shops around you within a certain
radius and yeah many of them accept
donations as well because they can reuse
your trophy sometimes it's just about
putting a new little name plate on the
trophy so if you don't want to ship it
off to one of these places in wisconsin
or maryland
you can obviously just go to your local
trophy shop and ask them also i do know
that goodwill will take a lot of
different trophies and awards as well so
you have options you don't have to cling
to them you don't have to throw them out
yeah yeah i love that idea that's that's
amazing mara i'd love to see you in a
few months ryan and i are going to be in
toronto we'll give you a couple tickets
to the love people use things
tour stop in toronto we'll also be in
vancouver both of those are in october
the minimalists.com
tour for tickets we're going to give a
live talk about minimalism a book
reading from our book love people use
things and we'll do a live version of
the minimalist podcast this week on the
maxwell episode ryan i want to talk to
you about some of your favorite moments
since we just finished the american leg
of the tour 18 cities down i realized
something that's our 10th tour in 12
years
ironically this is actually our longest
tour because we had to postpone some
dates because the weather and travel
restrictions and and covet et cetera but
we had to postpone some things so even
though it's only a 20 city tour
it ended up being like 13 months long oh
my goodness was it really that long yeah
because we started in september of last
year in texas yeah yeah and then october
will be the end of the love people use
things tour but on on the maximal this
week i want to talk to you about some of
your favorite moments because i'll tell
you this we had
some of my favorite events we've ever
had yeah legways chicago new york
yeah there's anyway we'll get into that
on denver was awesome oh my god denver
was like it was in a comedy club it felt
like a comedy show yeah it was good if
you missed any of those events you can
check them out on our patreon page
patreon.com
the minimalist we release one of those a
month once we get home and jordan and
podcast sean they um they start to edit
those together make it look beautiful
for our lovely patrons also this week on
patreon i want to share something um
about dumpsters about the dumpster
method we have a story from love people
use things that i read while we're on
the road i'm not gonna share it publicly
just yet but we'll share it on the
private podcast did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free